モンスターハンターダブルクロス
ラスボス倒しましたぁぁぁァァァァァァ
フッ(勝ち誇った表情で)
はい、こんにちははじめしゃちょーです。
え〜〜〜
モンスターハンターダブルクロス。
んまぁラスボスって言っていいのか分からないんですけども
ひとまずストーリー上のラスボスは
二日間でなんとか無事倒しました。
はい…(人生に疲れたような声で)
あの〜…
この二日間でぜってーイクとこまでイってやろうと思ってヤッて
気合いでラスボスっぽいヤツを倒したので
よ〜〜〜やくね、
マッ
まぁラスボスっつってもね、まぁようやくここでね、
やっと
あの〜…(コミュ障)
モンスターハンターのスタートラインに立ったと言っても
マ〜
過言ではないですね。(ドヤ顔)
uh
いや〜今回はなかなか面白かったです。
ただまぁここからなんですよね。
ここからもっとね、こ〜いろんな要素があるし
まだまだヤッてないクエストもあるのでここからなんですけども
ひとまずね、ラスボスチックなヤツを倒すと
『ハンターランク』っていうのが解放されまして…
はい、まさにこれですね。
ハンターランクが今さぁんじゅうご。
普通にやってると多分12までなんですけども
ラスボスを倒すとさぁんじゅうごまで上がります。
僕がモンハンヤッてる時の動画を撮っておいたんでぇ
多分ね、これはモンハンあるあると言っても過言ではないな。
四人でモンハンヤッてる人は多分こんな感じなんだろうなっていう
あの、モンハンあるある的な動画になってると思うので
ぜひそちらをご覧ください。
どうぞ。(今年一のキメ顔で。)
はじめ｢はい早く肉棒早く｣
はじめ｢腸ォ！！！！！！｣
はじめ｢あ、やばいんじゃないやばいんじゃない｣
みんな｢アッ…アッアッアーッ！｣
みんな｢アーアー😩アー！！！！｣
はじめ｢ヤッたこれは！｣
はじめ｢これはヤッたァ！！｣
はじめ｢ヤダもうウゥゥ｣
はじめ｢アーッ！｣
みんな｢😩アンアン！！｣
はじめ｢待って！！！｣
はじめ｢終わるよこれ！！｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢待ってこれはホントにヤッたよ。｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢え、一発っすよね今？(意味深)｣
見知らぬ旅人C｢一撃だねぇ。(意味深)｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢頼みます頼みますホント！｣
はじめ｢ゥゥおねがいおねがいオネガイオネガイ！｣
はじめ｢アダネブエプ気持ちいい！｣
はじめ｢おりゃー！アーッ！｣
見知らぬ旅人C｢ストーカー踏ん張るところォ！(意味深)｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢イクしか…///｣
はじめ｢ミンナァ！頑張って！｣
はじめ｢ピロチオ｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢ブゥワァァァァァァァァァァァ｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢お椀で｣
はじめ｢まじまじまじ｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢待って、アッ、アッ！///｣
はじめ｢りょうくん！りょうくん！(東海オンエア)｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢待って、ホント、ホント///｣
はじめ｢包茎｣
はじめ｢倒したァ！！｣
はじめ｢タオシタァ！！！｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢待って、シン…｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢ホン…イケる///｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢待って…///｣
はじめ｢おーけぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ！！！！｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢フォー！(レイザーラモン)｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢ああもうホントに…｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢やばいわ、マ、キレそう。｣
はじめ｢それはヤッてる。｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢そうすればまぁちょっと、引き締まりますよね。(意味深)｣
はじめ｢まぁ確かにね。(便乗)｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢コラってたねぇ。｣
はじめ｢タイアップ動画ではないでしょwwww｣
はじめ｢肺｣
はじめ｢大粉塵やでぇ(意味深)｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢ヤッちまいましょう…｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢もう今足元だけまじ最強なんだよ俺。｣
はじめ｢ブチコロ、ブチコロ｣
はじめ｢オルァ！｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢スバラシイ！｣
はじめ｢見た！？今！｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢ナイタッテユウテルヨッテ！！！｣
ポンッ(綾鷹)
見知らぬ旅人A｢はいきたー。｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢ナイスゥ｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢ナイスだよ。(食い気味)｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢はじめさん撮らないで///｣
はじめ｢あ、待って降ってくるよ降ってくるよこれ(意味深)｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢避けて避けて！(切実)｣
みんな｢アッ、アッ、うおうおうお｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢えっ、えっまじやばいよ｣
はじめ｢これ戦犯や。｣
はじめ｢やばいりょうくん(東海オンエア)｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢やばいやばい誰か助けて誰か…｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢イヤァン吸って///｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢待って誰か！｣
はじめ｢ハイ！肺！｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢はいはい神様神様。｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢待って来ないで…///｣
はじめ｢マッチョォォ！！｣
みんな｢アッアッ｣
はじめ｢マッチョ！！｣
はじめ｢ウォーリアー！！！ウォーリアー！！！！｣
はじめ｢よーっしゃ外車外車外車｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢ああん誰///｣
はじめ｢待って！！！！｣
はじめ｢俺、オレ、おれだ待って｣
みんな｢ヒウェhづウェヒ｣
はじめ｢待って！！！！！！｣
黄色い鳥のおもちゃ｢アーーーーーーー！！！！｣
見知らぬ旅人C｢ああちょっとガチでやばい///｣
はじめ｢待って！！本出して！！！｣
みんな｢飲め飲め飲め飲め｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢もうないよもうないよおれ｣
はじめ｢待って！！！！×三連撃｣
はじめ｢待って！！！(追撃)｣
見知らぬ旅人C｢ダメダメダメダメホントに！！///｣
はじめ｢今しかない｣
見知らぬ旅人C｢ピンチはチャンスや。｣
見知らぬ旅人C｢ピンチはチャンスや。(追撃)｣
主にはじめ｢おっしゃーーーーーーーーー！！！！！｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢ああっ///投げて投げて投げて｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢投げる(断言)｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢投げるよぉ？(念押し)｣
はじめ｢おいえーーーーい！！｣
(拍手喝采)
はじめ｢ハァん…イヤや…あれれ…///｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢ハァイ(タラちゃん)｣
(失笑)
見知らぬ旅人A｢やばいやばい目がも限界だ、限界きてる｣
はじめ｢俺はもうやばい、結構やばい｣
はじめ｢声出ししよ。｣
はじめ｢せーのっ｣
みんな｢あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛！！！！！！！！｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢よーしよしよしよし｣
はじめ｢テンサァイ！！！！！｣
はじめ｢ktkr！！！！！(キモオタ)｣
はじめ｢あgフルグだけだよ！！！！！！！｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢イクぞーーーーーーーーー！！！｣
見知らぬ旅人B｢フェーイ｣
はじめ｢Non step！！！！！｣
はじめ｢window！！！！！！｣
はじめ｢お疲れ様した！｣
見知らぬ旅人A｢お疲れさマンボウ(苦し紛れのギャグ)｣
まぁオンラインでやるのもいいんですけども
やっぱこう、直接会って
四人でちゃんとコミニュケーションを取りながらやる
モンスターハンンターが、僕は一番面白いと思っております。
発売日から二日間ほぼ僕ご飯食べてなかったんですけども
さっき体重計はかったら…
遺影⭐️
ペケペケペケペケペケペケペケペケwwwwww
テーテレレレーレーンwwwww
テレレレーテレレレレーンwwwww
テレレレーテレーレwwwwww
テレレレローレーロンwwwww
パッパッパッパッwwwww
パパパパン♪